[Music]
well good afternoon everyone and thank
you for coming to the session on the
last series of sessions on the first day
of Google cloud next my name is anthony
highlake and i'm a technical program
manager in google cloud and cute flow is
one of the partner programs that I am
responsible for and I'll pers be
presenting this afternoon session along
with a Vinod and Nicolas from a co h2o
AI so you can think of coop flow as as
tensorflow packaged up into kubernetes
containers to make it easier for
everyone to deploy develop and manage
their portable distributed machine
learning on kubernetes because what we
were seeing is people were doing this in
different ways and everybody had their
own solution their own architecture and
and everybody had had rolled their own
custom bespoke thing and what we started
the coop flow project we set out you
know what this looks a lot of like what
we were saying with containers before
kubernetes was developed back in 2014 so
everybody had their own way of
developing their their container
solution and we wanted to standardize
those api's and kubernetes has helped us
to do that and it allows the developers
to really focus on the higher value
things and not necessarily worry about
the infrastructure and how everything
else is it's plumbed together and so if
we already had that kubernetes why
wasn't it easy to just throw tend to
flow into the mix and everything work
well it turns out that there's a lot you
have to do in order to really make this
work especially the the portable
distributed portion of it so you would
have to become an expert in containers
and packaging kubernetes service
endpoints persistent volumes etc etc and
we just wanted to eliminate the
developer's responsibility with becoming
an expert in all of these and really get
them back to developing their
application and also once they develop
it once being comfortable that they
could run it in several different places
because the goal of coop flow was coop
flow is to run anywhere kubernetes runs
so if we could fix this we could really
make life easier for you and so that's
why we built cool flow we wanted to turn
having separate experimentation training
and cloud clusters and on the right-hand
side of this picture and this workflow
that you see on the left side which is a
traditional machine learning workflow
where you start at data ingest and then
you end up with logging and then the
loop feeds back on itself and then you
can retrain etc so what this becomes
with coop flow is your architecture
becomes excuse me a kubernetes
installation this workflow is taken care
of with coop flow and then you can do
experimentation on your laptop via mini
queue you can do training in your
on-premises cloud or some other small
cluster installation that you may have
and then you can push through the cloud
and again coop flow makes all of this
seamless because it's hiding all of the
the nuances of getting everything from
an infrastructure point of view
underneath the covers that is that is
kubernetes and coop flow maintains the
machine learning aspect the distributed
nature making sure you can use the
different resources whether it be CPUs
GPUs or TP use on Google cloud and so
what we wanted to do is to make it
easier to bring the subject matter
experts to machine learning because this
is that next level of unlocking that
we're trying to do because once we get
these subject matter experts with the
deep domain expertise that they can talk
more the language about the problems
they're trying to solve as opposed to
trying to have to deal with all of the
infrastructure and making sure
everything is plumbed together and works
correctly this is the vision that we
have and so with this introduction to
coop flow I'd like to turn it over to
Vinod and Nicolas from h2o to give an
example of some of the things that you
can do with coop flow thank you
[Applause]
thank you for the great introduction
thing I'm gonna skip in the next one
so I'm little diagur I've been in
Modesto for about three years I run a
lot of the product alliances and
marketing at issue so talk a little bit
about who we are as a company
good show of hands how many people have
heard of wattage to the company are used
one of our open source products it's
quite a few oh great perfect
so this one is I guess perfectly
redundant but we've been in business for
about six years right we are eventually
back company we are about a hundred
points now that number is little dated
some of the world's leading a experts
working
most folks knows for the h2o open-source
machine learning platform that's used by
over 14,000 organizations globally most
recently we launched a new product
called travelers AI which is our
automated solution we'll talk about that
a little bit detail later
you're headquartered in Mountain View
right across Google on the other side
earth the offices in London Prague in
India recently Gartner named us as a
leader in the machine learning and data
sense Magic Quadrant
they call this a technology leader with
the most completeness of vision what
that means what they mean by that is
that our technology bets our mind share
partner network ecosystem essentially
made as a quasi industry standard for
machine learning and AI when it comes to
enterprises so most of the vendors on
this quadrant for example they actually
use our open-source platforms under the
hood so that gives us a real credibility
in the enterprise one of the things that
I'm proud about is our customers gave us
the highest overall score among all
vendors for satisfaction relationship
account management support and that's
something that we take you know extreme
pride about be or we make sure that our
customers are get the best service and
experience so just to talk about the
h-2a product suite right so as I
mentioned most folks know us for the
open source products rather on the left
you see h2 open source extra core that's
been no call it internally
that's the in-memory distributed machine
learning algorithms that comes in our
Python or you can use the dredge to a
flow which
our own interactive notebook interface
there's sparkling water which is
essentially h2 a core that runs on top
of patches spark that's extremely
popular - nearly a third of all our
opens usage comes from that and last
year we made the decision to start
pouring some of these algorithms so two
GPUs so I'm talking about statistical
machine learning algorithms not just
deep learning which is already being
accelerated in GPUs we've poured it over
things like GLM's
random forests cranium boosted machines
clustering algorithms dimensional
diagram so the court traditional machine
learning outcomes those are now also not
ported over to GPS and on the right you
see our well write for you yes our
commercial offering first enterprise
offering called travel as AI which takes
all the benefits of open source but
packages it all together to give you
full automation end to end you can go
from data ingest all the way to
production all the intermediate steps
like engine feature engineering model
building training rapid primary tuning
are all taken care of for you so it I
mean our goal is very similar to as
Anthony said we our goal is to
democratize machine learning in a make
it really easy give the tools and
products for enterprises developers and
data scientists to do the jobs really
easily so that they can focus on solving
business problems so let me talk about
two core products over here and then
we'll see a demo later down by neck
who's gonna actually show how all our
products integrate really well with coop
flow and in general with Google Cloud so
if you are committed to using Google
cloud and if you saw the keynote today
there's a lot of amazing announcements
you can take advantage of all those
amazing new things with HT toes
offerings so very quick Ori on h2o we
call - - a core internally so what is it
it's essentially a math platform so it's
an open source in memory engine what
we're doing is we have taken the most
common machine learning algorithms like
as I mentioned the GLM's of the world
random forest creating booster trees and
you wrote them rewrote them from scratch
to be fully paralyzed and distributed so
you can essentially spin up multiple
machines as long as you're if your data
is large you just spit up more machines
and you can we can have all the data and
that really works well in the in the
kubernetes and cupola paradigm - so
because you when you are training on
small data on your laptop rigs
then if you're under the bus to cloud
for for much logic I said it's extremely
easy to do that it is written in Java
but we do offer a really robust REST API
that allows you to run it from hard
Python or h2o flow which is our own web
UI and of course you know it is built
for handling big data
so people outrun you know terabytes of
data and even gone to like hundreds of
terabytes of data without an issue you
can use all of your data you don't
really need to sample that's the real
value proposition of h2o so what kind of
algorithms do you support so this is
just a select list of for some other
algorithms as you can see most of these
classic statistical learning algorithms
tree based methods neural networks deep
learning dimensionality reduction
algorithms and we also support a lot of
unsupervised learning techniques like
clustering time series stuff like high
slacks were to embedding like birtwick
and tf-idf but in addition we do a lot
of high parameter tuning options that
are given and in an easy-to-use format
one of the things we did is we created
very thoughtful defaults for each of
those parameters so that even as a new
user if you don't know what those
parameters mean you don't have to figure
out you can still run a good model good
enough model and then come back and
start tuning them in addition we also
added an automatic machine learning
implementation so that it can run
through a whole bunch of algorithms try
a bunch of tuning parameters for you all
automatically and give you a good result
so when you think about the typical
machine learning workflow you know going
back to and they slide on the left side
if you will right so you have your data
integration happening bring data in from
different silos or tables do your joins
if you will and once you've done you
have a machine learning rate data frame
at which point you do feature
interesting model building and a model
deployment so h2ax essentially it's two
or three essentially fits in the model
building and deployment stage so you
need to do your own feature engineering
you need to do your data core
transformation but once the data is in a
good enough format you can use the h2
algorithms to run on the whole data set
and both models so from an architecture
perspective this is how it looks what
happens under the hood is you have on
the Left you got all the data sources or
we support every most common enterprise
data sources pulling data from a term
you have once the data is in h2o
the h2 data frame essentially it's a
distributed key-value store that
disturbs the whole data across all the
nodes you did you you have up and
running and this is all abstracted away
for the end user end user doesn't need
to know how many you know how the
distribution is happening and then you
can do exploration analysis and feature
engineering you can run one of the
different algorithms we support go
through a pyramid tuning do the
evaluation scoring and all of these
steps do you do in h2o are all fully
distributed for you under the hood so we
take care of the work like doing the
non-blocking cache tables the doing the
in-memory mapreduces distributed fork
joints all those things are fully
abstracted so you as a Hindu State don't
have to worry so what do you write what
are the code that runs on your laptop
will the one change one minor change
will run on a cluster so it's as either
set and then the cool part is after
you've done all the modeling you can
export the artifacts as either a plain
old Java object or a model object and
deploy it into a whole bunch of scoring
environments this code is highly
optimized for low latency scoring so
you're talking about microsecond a
millisecond level latency and it is
completely independent of the training
cluster so you can shut down the
training cluster take the scoring out if
I can put it to deployment anywhere so
it's a really clean end to end story for
each prizes and even for any data center
right so that is h2o core open source so
let's look at travel assay I for a
second right so what is our share so we
think of it as an expert data scientist
in a box so what we did is we took all
the learnings we had from or five or six
years of open source usage from the
community and from our customers and we
took the learnings from that and created
the software so sessions are built by
the experts expert data scientists are
build the software we taken their best
practices their heuristics their
workflows and codify that into the
software I'm sure most people already
here have heard about kaggle right so if
not Kaggle is this data science portal
where people host Psychonauts actually
old by Google as well ago but we've
essentially hired file the top 100 grand
masters from kaggle and we took their
work
and basically codified so you're
essentially getting Grandmaster level
machine learning in this product and how
do we do that
so again let's go back to this
enterprise machine learning workflow so
you have data is coming in from
different sources you still need to do
that you need to do the ETL part you
need to do the data cadre transformation
as well we do some of it but not a whole
lot but once the data is in in a single
data source if you will a single file or
in a frame at that point on you can let
drabble us take care of everything
so we do that all the feature
engineering for you we'll do the one out
encoding will do the target encoding
will do dimensionality reduction for you
we'll find the right interaction
elements and all of those things
automatically for you depending on the
type of the data set type of problem
solving to solve all as you need to do
as a user to specify what you're trying
to predict and will take care of from
that point on and then in parallel we do
model building as well so it's very
intertwined process feature engineering
and model building back and forth
iteratively and goes through this entire
process to give you a pipeline this
pipeline will now have that all the fee
changes that it thought very useful and
the model final model or ensemble that
it picked to be the most effective and
this pipeline is generated as code for
you so again going back to our original
paradigm you want deployment ready cord
that is independent of training cluster
so you can take the cord and deploy in
the production and on the edge if you
want to and finally we do another cool
thing is we actually try to interpret
the model for you so what you're trying
to solve is three things there's a lot
of things happening in the slide but
essentially it's talent time and Trust
we found that those are the three big
reasons hurdles obstacles to enterprise
AI adoption so talent is there is
there's a deep lack of expertise and
that's no news to anyone the data
scientists are hot commodity do fine and
they are extremely rare to you know hire
and keep as well right so what do all
the enterprise around the world do so
that's a big challenge the second
problem is of time it takes a lot of
time to build models train them
effectively and even with all the
advances that have happened in the
hardware side you don't have the
software to take advantage of it and
finally even when son see both the good
model these models often don't go too
production because the business uses
don't trust them the enterprises that
regulators are afraid of black box
models there is inherent lack of trust
in the air so how do we solved all those
these problems basically we saw that by
using driverless AI to deliver the
digital data scientists that can solve
the talent problem you can make your
existing workforce more effective we
solved at the time problem by automating
the entire workflow and also using the
latest GPUs and hardware to accelerate
the machine learning workflow itself so
you can give your results in a matter of
hours instead of what would take weeks
or months and finally every model be
built we are able to generate
explanations for you that are fully
interpretable so the question comes up
how accurate are we I mean automation is
cool or demos the buzzword now but is it
any good so what we did is we actually
took travelers AI to task and we
participated in Kaggle as a bot so in
some of the competitions so this one in
particular is pretty cool the BNP
paribas this was a year old
out-of-the-box driverless say I came
number 10 on the leaderboard out of
about 3,000 participants so just for
context right so the all the people who
were higher ranked higher than
driverless CI on average had about
anywhere from ten to twenty five
submissions some a couple of people had
like over hundreds of submissions and
then these people spend weeks if not
months to get a higher score and in a
matter of a few hours Travelocity I came
ranked number ten
so it can give perform at the level of
an expert Kaggle Grandmaster that's what
we are talking about here right and this
is not just one competition we
participate a bunch of other
competitions and it typically comes in
the top five and sometimes top one
percentile without any human
intervention and just to give you a
sneak preview of what's happening under
the hood right so you're talking about
this features these are the features
that get created some of these
automatically generated features like
things like text handling frequency
encoding cross validated target encoding
and to get it a sweetie for example
these are all complex features that a
they are you don't know if you know how
to use them it's it's painful to
actually code them up in Python and then
try to run them on all the different
combinations if possible right so
it's a lot of time and effort that
required if you know the expertise and
we do that all for you automatically so
one final thing about deployment after
the model is built as I mentioned
earlier you do get a job artifact so you
can get the mojo mojo for h2o and for
travelers also you can get the module
file that's essentially a zip file that
contains the binary representation at
the model and it also contains all the
feature engine information and it's
completely self independent right it's
self-sufficient doesn't have any
dependencies you can put it into the
edge you can run it better berry you
have a Java runtime environment and
obviously it's easy to add other
language bindings to but that's a really
cool deployment story so you can have
one of these models running on your
phone for example and will still give
you low latency scoring it can give you
some millisecond response times so you
don't have to call it a stay PII or an
endpoint if you don't have to you can
embed these applications in your in your
software cool with that
I am gonna invite Nick Nicholas over to
talk about how does h2o fit into Google
cloud Sparkle hello everyone so we're
just gonna talk of a couple things first
off is just a couple of pipelines that
we've kind of run on GCP slash played
with in GCP as a kind of preamp to the
final one which is our demo on cue flow
obviously it being in the title it
should come last and be the most
important thing so firstly we have just
a high-level deployment of kind of like
the pipeline that we might suggest if
you were already utilizing spark so a
lot of companies you know already use
spark as part of their data engineering
platform what this does provide to you
is the ability to ingest data directly
through Google Data proc which is
Google's offering of Apache spark and
it's it makes things very easy because
you don't have to set up the
infrastructure Google sets up and pulls
up the infrastructure for you and then
what we can do is actually play on top
of that using our offering of sparkling
water
and h2o and you can do your data munging
you can do your data engineering and
then once you're done with that you can
output the final file into driverless AI
from here driverless AI can do all the
wonderful things that Vinod did mention
we will allow for feature automatic
feature engineering automatic hyper
parameter tuning and model building and
then you can serve the serve the final
model out as a mojo or a Python scoring
package in again GCE now both driverless
AI and the the Mojo scoring pipelines
can all be served on VMs in GC in the
GCP so on Google compute engine and the
nice thing is that you can actually have
a smaller platform that doesn't
necessarily need you know GPUs to serve
Mojo's because they don't actually need
the GPS so then another one just another
quick pipeline that we did have is just
going straight from bigquery and this
does highlight a little bit of the
integration work that we've done as far
as data ingest with driverless AI
essentially the data still stored in one
this case it would be stored directly in
bigquery the the other ones obviously
are kind of moot in this case but you
can do the data munging directly in
bigquery meaning you know formulate a
select statement or formulate a sequel
query that that gets you the data that
you want at which point you can actually
just copy paste that same sequel
statement directly into the driverless
AI UI through the data ingest at which
point you would be able to just simply
ingest that data and driverless will
grab that data and then be able to run
with it same back end of the pipeline
and finally we're gonna just talk a
quick a quick highlight before we get to
a demo here of just like h2o plus cube
flow so the idea being is that the one
nice thing about kubernetes and cube
flow in general is that one kubernetes
allows you to distribute your your
workload so you don't necessarily need
to give over a whole machine to UM to a
program that's running you know or only
really needs one CPU and maybe a couple
of gigs of ram to support it right now
obviously
a lot of this stuff I H to a core
product in Drive let's say I would
require significantly higher resources
but the nice thing is if you had a
cluster on gke the you're able to
distribute the workload for hto core and
then maybe also on top of this and this
is something I'll show in the example
also deploy another another pod that
contains driver list and it's all
running on the same infrastructure it's
all very easy to do because all you need
to do is just give it to docker
containers one for h2o one for
driverless AI which we do provide cool
so at this point let me just sign in
here okay so we're gonna just go over a
quick demo now what I have here is on
the left-hand side is going to be the
github repo so this is actually public
its h2o AI /h 2oq flow so if you take a
look up here this is actually going to
be merged into the actual queue flow
repo eventually I think at the moment we
have an open issue for it and then I
just want to kind of show you my
infrastructure right now we have a quick
small demo cluster so it's a it's not
tiny but it's not enormous either but
basically it comes down to we have about
32 cpus plus some X number of RAM and
it's a gke cluster so it's running on
Google GCP and also another quick look
but basically the two VMs that's that's
all that is there so on the right hand
side we have a terminal now cute flow
basically allows you to use something
called case on it as a package that
allows for templating and this is one of
the really great things of queue flow in
my opinion as in addition to kubernetes
is kubernetes itself you when you want
to make a deployment you have to create
a yamo file or a manifest file and say
explicitly that this is the the the
runtime environment that my container
needs to have and now if i go part two
if for example my my original container
was a testing container and only needed
you know four CPUs and a bit of RAM to
go along with it then the next one
needed to be
much more much more powerful than you
would have to actually change the the
Yamma file you'd have to actually change
the manifest request more resources and
that can be a pain in the butt
especially if you you know are not in an
environment where you can easily change
these things or if you're trying to do
it automate it automatically right the
cool thing with queue flow is that if
you do kiss in it and so this is
actually the directory that has already
been knitted but I'll actually go back
just to show you kind of the idea behind
it so if I do chaos in it and then demo
demo demo what that'll do is create yep
sorry
chaos in it damn oh damn oh what that's
doing is actually creating a folder
organizing cube CTL to point to that
specific folder and and in basically
setting up the runtime environment under
which you can actually deploy cube flow
i deploy cube flow as well as deploy
anything else within that that area so
now we'll actually go back to queue flow
demo here next sorry and so what you'll
see here is basically what caisson it
has created so you'll see some
environments you'll see some components
and you'll see an abdominal so if we
look into components here what that's
showing you is some of the components
that I've already added caisson it
allows you to add a registry now our
registry actually adds a pack or adds a
list of packages that you can install
after which you install specific
packages so if I do KS pkg list you'll
actually see that I've been it'll
actually show you the asterisk shows
that it's installed here so I've
installed our h2o package I've also
installed driverless AI I've installed
the queue flow core packages right and
these are all running so if I do cube
CTL get pods I actually have a couple of
them running already pre-baked so that I
can actually show you what's going on on
the back on the front end as well as on
the back end so from the point where
we're at here you've installed the
packages using Kay
pkg install and then you'd actually just
right out so it'd be h2o cube flow in
this instance and then I can do slash H
2 O 3
galing because I haven't so I haven't
installed this package it's basically a
work in progress but it gives you the
example of how you would install set
package from here if we CTO get pods get
SVC so this is actually showing you the
endpoints I'm using a load balancer to
expose the port number so that I can
actually use their api's in in the web
browser or in a jupiter notebook or
something of the sort but then the last
step after you've installed the package
would be KS prototype use io dot k
sonnets dot PKG dot h 2 o 3
static and this is basically like the
first line and you can actually read
through a lot of these deployment steps
here in the repo so i'm not gonna go any
further than giving you kind of the the
first step but this what this is doing
is this actually creating those
components that i showed you initially
so again if you LS into the components
you can see that after using prototype
use what you get is this component
installed in the case on it app and if
you'll notice here you would have had to
take a couple parameters and pass a
couple parameters so actually that's
gonna be this file right here so if you
take a look at the parameters you can
actually see that we've it sets some
parameters for each of the components
that have been deployed okay so now
we're actually going to just dive a
little bit deeper into after you've
deployed so sorry just one last quick
thing ki supply is going to be how you
actually deploy so ki supply the
specific environment that you want and
then also the components so
in this case H 2 O 3 static would be one
of the components that I had already
created when you do that that's what
what you're ultimately going to get is
the package along with the parameters is
going to be passed to cube flow and
that's going to deploy your packages and
pull up as many replicas as we requested
as well as pull up the specific
resources allocated to each pot so now
we're gonna go quickly first to the h2o
deployment and this is HDL core so if
you go to the external API in the load
balancer and it's just HTTP and then
five four three two one which is the
exposed port you can see that this is
h2o flow so this is actually what Vinod
was talking about earlier this is our
basically simplified GUI so it's very
similar to Jupiter notebook in the sense
that it gives you kind of a kind of a
step through notebook and you can do
some more simplistic steps rather than
coding this in Python you can actually
just go like import files and I can set
a variable that says variable is LOC a
for location a is equal to some string
here and then and then import the import
the file just like this and instead of
using you know pythonic language it's
very clearly you know just one step next
do the next thing right and I'm gonna go
ahead and leave that now so now if we go
to a Jupiter notebook sorry about that
open up the demo so I have just
basically this is just a quick notebook
kind of showing you what would happen
you would import and this this would be
from your local computer you can import
the h-2a packages connect to the
specific URL plus endpoint and this
it'll show you that it'll actually show
you the resources so we have a cluster
of three nodes that's because that's the
deployment package that I made go ahead
and import some data go ahead and set up
some data and this is this is running
through a demo that's on our
documentation so if you do look at Doc's
to oai you can actually see the same
demo or something fairly similar
ultimately what this is coming down to
is we're running on h2 autumn ml package
the auto ml meaning that it's going to
do mace an intense grid search across
several different algorithms that we
have and try and find the best one and
you can track progress here basically
all I've done is set a single parameter
here saying that don't run more than 120
seconds but basically take any
algorithms that you want try as much as
you can and give me the best possible
result so while that's running I'm
actually going to show you the other
product that's running which is
driverless AI so driverless AI it's
exposed at this IEP IP right here and
just the port number one two three four
five so if I go one two three four five
you'll see driverless AO is running and
I've actually loaded a couple data sets
already in case you're not familiar with
this the first step would be going
through and adding a data set we do have
direct integration to Google bigquery as
well as Google Cloud Storage so if I
were wanting to go to Google bigquery
again you can go and type in the data
set ID right here you can type in the
the GCS bucket right here and then you
can do some sort of selects a select you
know a select star from data set just in
the interest of time I'm actually just
going to close that window and show you
from what we have already so what I have
here is a one time series data set so
this is a Walmart data set that was from
Kaggle basically it's predicting the
weekly sales of a Walmart stored in in
series of time so the first thing that
driverless AI does is it gives you a
couple options straight from the data
set tab first you can describe it so
basically what this is doing is giving
you some statistical inference it's
telling you what type of values they are
how many values there are and if there
are any missing mean min max just some
very basic statistics a lot of you would
kind of see something fairly similar if
you went to pandas and did pandas
describe the next thing that we do have
is visualizations so this is a package
that we call Auto this Auto this
basically gives you the opportunity to
you to create visualization plots
automatically so driverless does this
automatically for you and what it's
going to show is a lot of the plots that
as a data scientist you probably want to
know outlier plots are very important
seeing if that may be for some reason
the whole distribution is here but for
some reason there's some some data
points that are kind of lying way out on
the side and so this would be on a
specific column here and if you kind of
scroll through you can see each
different column and you know the same
goes for you know you can get radar
plots you can get histograms or skewed
histograms correct correlation graphs
are also really cool and you can see the
correlation between store or is holiday
everything seems to be correlated is
holiday and that that makes a lot of
sense considering this is retail and
then after this you can create an
experiment so let's this is the the
first steps we're all like oh is the
data good is did I import the right data
set did I do I feel comfortable with
running experiment on this once I go
there now I can go to predict I'm ready
to do a prediction and so at this point
you can run a prediction and that means
adding a test dataset if you so choose
if you do not add a test dataset it's
fine driver let's say I will notice and
automatically use cross-validation folds
to test and train so it will do out of
do testing on validation on the out of
fold out of fold data
so that you don't ever have to worry
about about cheating essentially so time
column this is a time series data set
it's one of those things where we do
need to address time and we don't want
to look at September to predict August
sales right so you can always set auto
auto for time column otherwise if you
know the specific time column you can
actually go in and say okay well that's
actually just the date and then from
here you can actually select how many
weeks do you want to predict forward
how many weeks after do you want to
predict and always Auto is optional
otherwise you can you know go in and
select it more specifically the finally
is you set a target column so this in
this case would be weekly sales and from
here you get the final step which is do
you select your score so RMS see our
Miceli RMS PE MA these are all scores
for regression and the reason is is
because you're predicting revenue so
this this would be a regression problem
and you have three knobs accuracy time
and interpretability interpretability is
just how interpreted will do you want on
a scale of 1-10 zero interpretability
row interpretability or one would mean
that you don't mind having a very
complex model versus ten is saying make
it as simple as possible make it so that
the the feature transformations are all
very clear and easy to understand time
less time means you know take a less
take take a shorter amount of time to
run or more time meaning take longer to
run i don't mind
run as long as you need accuracy how
high do I prioritize accuracy so is
accuracy more important can I have a
more complex model things like that at
which point then you can click Launch
experiment so once you launch it'll give
you this kind of UI from here you can
watch as as we progress through the
epics and see more iterations as
variables change you'll see variable
importance here and you can check on CPU
usage an actual versus predicted graph
as well as kind of some just logging and
trace values up front I actually have
already completed data or pass so I'm
actually just going to show you that
right here so that we can talk about it
a bit but what it comes down to is you
can see now the the graphics
filled itself in you can actually take a
look here this is kind of cool because
this is actually showing that the only
the only data point that was actually
kept that is from the original data set
is a department at the top five so you
can see that some of them are target
lagged values other one of them is a
clustered value so this is using a
clustering algorithm of our making so we
clustered the values between department
and markdown number four and from that
we actually created a new value that is
going to become the value in that column
and then finally there's also another
lag but value at the top here so the
other thing you can take a look at here
is the iteration so over time it started
out with a couple models and you can see
there's some outlier models which were
really really not high performant
obviously are messy meaning the lower
are messy the better right so so we
started out at around a 2600 rmse and
then finally the the final model they
were predicting is a little bit less
than that so over time basically and
this is you know if we had given it more
time if we made it a little bit less
interprete ballif we had higher
prioritize accuracy it'll-it'll progress
a little bit more but for these for
these settings this is kind of what you
would expect is that over time would
progressing find a certain point where
it would stop because it said okay this
was good enough this is kind of what you
were expecting and I'm just going to
quickly kind of talk about this we
didn't run a pre-baked MLI but this is
machine learning interpretability
essentially what it comes with is three
packages or three surrogate models a
random forests a decision singular
decision tree and kale I'm so kale I'm
is essentially lime but K number of lime
models what that does is creates a
series of linear models essentially that
approximate what the what the actual
model is doing so it's basically trying
to give you linear betas the same idea
is like a linear regression you have a
beta on each point that will explain why
a certain how the a change in that data
point would affect the the prediction so
that's K line the next one is random
forests which will give you loco
plots which are basically feature
importance but back and forth are
positive and negative there's also
feature importance which is just
positive and then finally there's a
decision tree which allows you to make
RC like trace the path of a singular
decision tree very straightforward if I
saw it at this specific column why I
made a decision
[Music]